hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it who do I see
goddammit douchey I polish up a grenade
up your ass it's it's no match for the
power of children but there's a pretty
good attempt
where the hell even are you I'm in a
different location from my safety I pay
top dollar for this security room Toshi
are you talking to your friends again
who's that oh it's just the head of my
security guards um that'll be all for
this is there any way to talk to your
mother
it's not working do she no way she's my
security officer but it isn't that right
for this are you passed debated again
Bob
just stop doing it to the pictures of
the Queen Abaddon sorry mom fine but
dinners in three you have dinner at
three my curfews at six I know you many
more mistakes and doing sergeant critic
videos and you need to pay for it
indeed I have now since you've all been
waiting for it especially me
yes this is the next cop 11 nostalgia
critic fuck-ups
down and short if
everything
the word
No
ah where's your old versus new award the
world indeed a lot of people have been
wondering what happened since I said in
my list I was going to do an old versus
new of war of the worlds' a lot of
people think the timing was so show
distracted from it but actually there's
another reason I did watch both movies
again and to be 100% honest neither of
them held up very well to me
I mean neither one was terrible or
anything but they both seemed
surprisingly underwhelming when I was
younger and I saw these movies I was
really drawn in to him I found the
spaceships in both versions were really
frightening and the panic very
legitimate but now that I'm older
watching them again there's not a whole
lot to them it's just people running
away from aliens that's it granted the
twist ending is very cluttered of course
they came from the original book but
aside from that it's just people running
and screaming the characters are bland
the spaceships don't look that
interesting and the aliens are well
stupid seriously does a target just need
to design every original alien nowadays
all the aliens look the same well ok the
original aliens didn't look the same but
they just looked like a GUI version of
the game Simon I just couldn't find that
much to compare neither one seemed like
the better movie now at the time they
came out that's a different story
you can probably talk a lot about the
influence the first film had and even
the Fearne panic the remake recaptured
but they just didn't age that well and I
simply couldn't come up with enough
material to write a decent review for it
sorry guys but this is one old versus
new you're never going to see from me
Laurita
that wasn't a Victorian dress in
Superman for you can't pocket yes in my
crossover review with Linkara of
Superman for we said that the dress that
the woman was wearing here was a
Victorian style dress actually it's an
18th century dress and the Victorian era
with the 19th century you are
how the hell do you know so much about
historical clothing just a hobby that uh
Joshi where do you want me to put your
coffee not really too much I can say
about this we simply got the time era of
the dress wrong but needless to say was
like ours fault that's right don't
believe me take a look at this video
apology that he made earlier this week
hello I'm Lynn Cara and I totally fucked
up sorry I feel like an ass
holding car you don't have to be so hard
on yourself no really it was totally my
fault I should have known not to upset
someone as powerful and handsome as you
oh and Cara are you saying that I'm so
physically attracted that I'm turning
you gay right now yes yes I am well I
just don't know what to say Jaime I'm
just speechless that credit card bad
credit card
this is reasoning mr. freethinker his
white ass in my Batman and Robin review
I point out that freeze had a cure for
the disease that Alfred has which
happens to be the exact same disease
that freeze his wife had I asked the
question why he didn't just give that
cure to his wife to begin with well
actually they do explain it though very
briefly mr. death it is freezing
technology to reverse MacGregor's
syndrome he's even found a cure for the
disease in certain stages but Alfred
thankfully was in an earlier stage that
he could cure
Alfred's condition is less severe
freezes research said he cured a case
like Alfred's you just didn't say how so
everything turned out fine I guess a big
concern in the Batman movies whether or
not that Butler will die thank God all
the psychological turmoil of a man who
dresses up like a bat as parents die
nice best dress was like trying to fight
crime yeah that that's tiring
the butler done there's the drop the
movie doesn't get any more shocking than
that well of course except for the
appearance ova the bad nipples why want
to care about the bat nipples they were
in the last movie oh oh I apologize I
must have seen that wrong sorry huh let
me just change my reaction accordingly
crack
you never see anybody's name right
well maybe not everybody's name oh I
write comments on the Internet therefore
that means I'm right well you're sort of
correct but uh there's been a couple of
names that for whatever reason I could
never quite pronounced correctly like
judge Hirsch instead of Judd Hirsch
Ralph Bakshi instead of Ralph Bakshi but
the biggest one people seem to harp on
the most is make oh god damn it won't he
leave me alone everybody's been telling
me that his name is pronounced Mach Oh
instead of Mako but to be honest I've
heard it both ways I've heard a lot of
people call him Mako in the past does
that mean that they're all wrong
probably but that's not the point to me
it's just a tomato tomahto thing some
people just say it differently than
others and to be honest I've been
calling him Mako for this long I don't
see any point in changing it there now
will you go away good god I never had a
dead person annoy me so much for him
that's nothing devil from Fantasia again
I think this one is sort of debatable
according to a lot of people and even
many of them from Disney the monster on
Bald Mountain is a creature named chip
Chernabog sure a bug sure tomato tomahto
so everyone kept pointing out to me that
this was in fact not the devil but let's
really look at this for a second you got
a horn creature with minions dancing
around and bathing in fire celebrating
all that is evil and the only thing that
can stop him is the sound of church
bells and Ave Maria it's the devil who
are you kidding you can call a mr.
fluffy for all I care and it would still
be the devil oh yeah and this little bit
of information might mean something Bald
Mountain according to tradition is the
gathering place of Satan and his
followers devil that's the fucking devil
what more do you need
oh well if you want to call him churn
butter or whatever his name is that's
fine
but for me and I think everybody who saw
this for the very first time it's the
devil devil
the house mother didn't die from a
disease you a stick-on yes when I did my
review of the show full house I said
that the mother died from some sort of
unknown disease but people explained to
me that actually she was killed in a car
accident I don't know I don't remember
it being mentioned I have to admit I
have no memory of it but so many people
swore that was mentioned that I'm not
gonna debate them but at least we can
all agree it was a shitty show that is
made clear I'll admit I'm surprised at
how many people follow full house lore
but there it is I mean Who am I to doubt
the logic of internet commentators
imagine you epoxy on your houses box yes
a box major of packs please stop it
dolphins kick punch you anti don't fight
shows you what watching the Discovery
Channel can teach you according to
scientist dolphins really can defend for
themselves against sharks by literally
punching them that's an interesting
little fact that I probably never will
figured out but still I don't know this
scene from Zeus and Roxanne still seems
pretty goofy to me I mean she punches
the shark right in the friggin teeth
that seems a little unrealistic we see
in slow-mo the shark literally takes a
little chunk off of her and yet there's
never any battle scars and on top of
that the dolphin is friggin huge I mean
I know dolphins are big but not that big
what was the dolphin just on steroids
for the past few seconds I don't know it
may seem scientifically correct but to
me it's still just seems silly
I went for kami that did explain a few
things this is another one where
technically you're right but it's not
explained very well like I guess the
reason for the four is being able to
move and fly and such is that it was
enchanting that's a pretty blanket
statement it's just enchanted that's it
well I guess technically that's
explaining it how about the magic potion
that merges men into metal he said he
just got in from some witches but when
we seen witches those exist in Camelot
it's like saying he bought it from a
bunch of munchkins it just seems out of
place but again technically it's
explained so I can't complain but here
are some things that are never explained
why did the chicken switch from good to
evil and if you say to get to the other
side I'll fucking kill you
why did putting his caliber in the stone
magically Hugh everybody and if it could
magically heal everybody why did they do
that before that's unbelievable that's
like the world's greatest Hospital in a
sore and if it could heal everybody why
did it healed Garrett's blindness those
are things that are still never
explained in any fashion no words are
ever mentioned nothing has ever shown it
just sort of happens so in my opinion
there's still a lot of stuff that needs
to be explained but for the few things
that are explained I apologize
that was Jim Killeen singing the whole
time your brain is fart
it's funny how not only do I make this
mistake twice but both in the exact same
review when I listed the top 11 greatest
villain songs I brought up that
Christopher Lloyd and Jeremy Irons were
more speaking their songs rather than
singing them little did I know that both
of these songs were actually sung by a
famous voice actor Jim Cummings who
dubbed their voices so perfectly I
couldn't even tell the difference and I
don't think a lot of other people could
either I thought what's the most
mystical man and of Russia with the
Royal brightly they made of it okay
in fact Jeremy Irons actually does start
singing his song but by the end I guess
his voice gave out or something so they
gave it to Jim Cummings again point but
I got a sniffle on me
for the cool of the country be prepared
that's unbelievable he can actually
replace another person's voice while
their voice was still in the song that
guy has mad skills yeah it was a fuckup
but it was a fuckup that at least gives
credit to the talent of a great voice
actor and there's nothing wrong with
that
number two
nine plus nine plus nine is twenty-seven
yet dummy yeah this is about as
embarrassing as it gets even simple
first grade math seems to slip my radar
sometimes in my end of days review I
make an elaborate puzzle that mocks how
the mathematical clues in the movie
we're pretty much over the top
do you know anything about the number of
the beast 666 the number of the beast is
not 666 often their dreams numbers
appear upside down backward so 666
becomes 999 like in 1999 the year of his
return
am I not so well thought out explanation
I say the nine plus nine plus nine is
twenty-one not 27 what the hell was I
thinking
I'm really having problems with numbers
that Dora the Explorer can figure out
that's just an excusable how dare you
how dare you for a decade they went
around thinking named his name because
nine with 21 because of you the review
hasn't been out for decades years nope
months
sure whenever I'm thinking it because of
you you should be ashamed of yourself
don't you have any other problems to
complain about don't you have a whole
world out there to interact with I am in
a world of warcraft' important ography
if there is nothing else
next I'm complaining about the news -
don't you mean Chernabog
and the number one next nostalgia critic
fuckup is
nothing I have no number-one haha I
guess I didn't make as many mistakes as
I thought well thank you for joining me
in time
did you hear something I totally didn't
hear anything don't try to avoid me I'm
not avoiding you think that I don't hear
you're missing the autism Joe you know
damn well that you made a joke about
autism and you tried your heart is never
to mention it again
all right in my Ernest saves Christmas
review I made probably the most
inappropriate joke ever it was when one
of the characters is doing an unfunny
puppet show for kids that are way too
old to be enjoying it yes I think he
entertains the autistic children not
only was this inappropriate it just
didn't make sense there's just as many
high functioning autistic people as
there are low functioning autistic
people in fact there's even more high
functioning I know autistic people and
to be honest this was just an unfair
unthought out joke I didn't even think
it was that funny when I put it in I
just sort of did it on the off chance
that maybe someone else would find it
funny it was a gamble and to this day it
remains to be the only joke I ever
removed because I simply thought was low
and unfair
no disrespect people is just a really
stupid mistake that I hope never to make
again feel awkward enough so do I so
let's end today with me say oh there's
so much more I need to bitch and moan
about that's it where are you I'm gonna
lay my vengeance upon thee ah
you'll never find me my location is
sealed probe Dushi
do you want another bitch it's Gone Wild
video ever know there must be someone
else why do we keep getting these videos
I mean is it really so hard to see that
I address is what to find Arthur Street
in my TV oh hey wait we don't do it your
videos don't mean that much me I didn't
even notice them ma don't open the door
oh hi mr. critic sure adieu she can play
he's right downstairs no no you chicken
blowing little stir
that's a grenade that's a grenade
yeah ask him if he wants to stay for
dinner
Oh
are you masturbating again